okay hi everyone welcome to another
live stream talking about incremental
language development
for wolfram language so we have an
assorted collection of topics here first
up is geoposition picker
right so this is a discussion we started
last week and
well it's hard to design something that
selects a position in a map
right okay so we we discussed several
things we discussed having a control
that is kind of slider-like and we
discussed having
a um a thing that can be used in a form
function
right right
okay so something else sorry go ahead
what do you mean slider like well i just
mean that it has a
you know a variable called you know p
or something where you say uh
you know g opens
what does file name set up
something of dynamic of points well i
was confused because that's
exactly what we use in form functions so
there's no
those are not two different things we
use the same interfaces manipulate
fine so so what works with manipulate
would work for us okay so file setter
what is it called file name
okay so this seems like a model doesn't
it
whether it's just a geo position as the
you know so geo position setup first
argument geoposition
um you know and then it's got all kinds
of detail
about does that seem right
to live in the control world yes
absolutely although the second the
second argument is not going to be doing
the kinds of specifications that
filename setter does
no no i understand it will be just
telling you what map to show by default
well what we were talking about before
you arrived is that would be
like it would be like just like for
slider we design
restrict the second argument of
restricted the same
in the case of geoposition the second
argument of the decision is
an area so like a geo region so you you
could say
uh sng location picker dynamic of x
comma united states
and you would not be able to select
something in europe
i i think that what kind of map stuff
like that can be options
i understand but i i think you should i
think it should show you
the us by default but if you if you
dynamically pan to europe it should
still work
well i i disagree i think that
like you can have a starting geo range
that does what you just said
but usually if you look at the design of
things like slider the second argument
restricts what you can actually
set the dx to i understand that i
understand
well i don't i don't see the use case
for that that's the point
i mean the name will be geoposition
center right so it will be
position and then region
is what you're proposing what would be
the default region
the earth
well probably default would be more like
what
geo um dynam
like dynamic geographics and utilizes to
why not
like i think that's default wrong but
dynamic channel
i think the default for dynamic
geographic should probably be the earth
this is a separate question that we have
don't think i'm opposed
it's gonna say we've been sort of
gradually switching
you know more and more things to whole
world defense yes
i i think this is this definitely always
strikes me as goofy i'm always a little
bit embarrassed when it comes up
well but it's it's your look i mean i
have no problem in changing to the wall
because it feels
natural but this also feels natural
because it's your own area so you are
you are typically interested in things
in your own area
yes well
i mean on the other hand my internet
connection
you know i don't know depending on what
the service is
you know it always thinks i'm over by
peoria right and i mean
seven 000 miles away uh i mean we could
have it default to something large and
ha
and then add another button next to zoom
once that brings up this
so your local area given your [ __ ]
and that would you know possibility for
words
we sent the whole of us as default
what's that as a european i resent the
whole of the us as a default for
everyone
no it's stupid but we don't want
the us we want the world
and as a as a terrestrial being you
can't complain about that
you could complain about what the
centering is but i think you know the
greenwich meridian centering is okay
okay so so next question is is it a
multi-selector or is it a single
selector
do you understand my question right so
locator pane can have multiple thumbs
can add thumbs at will
etc right and i kind of think that there
are two cases i think there's a geo
position setter
which is a single pick a place and be
happy
and there's a i mean there's a locator
pane type story
where you're selecting multiple places
and then returning them
and those seem like different actions
for the cloud also and for a form also
um yeah i mean so far we have
uh followed uh in the steps of filename
setter in that if you have like
repeating element of image you get
only one widget but you can upload
multiple images to it
so we we can do that
so what does it return does it return an
image in one case in a list of images in
the other case
yeah repeating element of image means a
list oh repeating element
oh i see right this isn't going to work
with repeating element i mean this is a
different thing this is i'm going to
put marks wherever i'm going to uh
you know visit on my tour of the
national park or something
yeah so why wouldn't that be the control
default controller for repeating element
of your location
it could be but the question is what's
the name of that object
right so i'm saying geoposition setter
should return one thing
your position set up well okay go on
yeah what i would say is that
uh file name setter and location pane
use the same symbol
for both things and i think it's a bit
clunky i think it would be cleaner to
have two separate symbols
sorry filename centered as what which
what filename setter
comma open list lets you open multiple
files and binds to a list of files
right just like locator pane can choose
multiple points there is a calling
signature for file name center where you
can choose multiple files
at once
um okay so wait a minute so what what is
your proposal in the end
two separate functions i i think we
should have two separate functions i
think that
having the same symbol do two things is
a little bit clunky sometimes okay so
you're saying geoposition setter
is is the one that returns a single
place
and then what's the other one
geoposition list
center well so then the question is does
it
literally return a list of genome
positions or does it return a multi-geo
position
all right i forgot about that
well that's a reason to allow
geoposition setter if it's returning a
multi-geo position
you can deal with
untangling that separately i mean if
your code
how do you tell let's say your code says
geodistance
from this place to whatever and it's a
multi-geo position what does it then
return does it return a list of geo
distances yes actually a quantity array
so it does an
outer or both if you put two multi geo
positions it will just return a matrix
okay
so okay so that
that suggests geoposition setter returns
a geo position or a multi geo position
and the interface will be like locate a
pane where you could do an
option click or whatever it is to get an
additional
uh thumb right what is it is it is it
come on what is the click
i always forget the details
and it's possible that the options to
locate your paint need to be set
in order to allow that i see i hope
that's the case because
it would be a madness if i couldn't
trust
it stripe to be inconsistent
but what are you talking about what
he's saying he doesn't want people to
accidentally do a multi
yeah when it's not i mean in forms it
would really break things and i'm sure
it would also manipulate if you would
select multiple things when you expect
only one individual yeah so so do we
have a design here so that it's geo
position setter
it returns either a geo position or a
multi geo position but it's always a geo
position it's never anything other than
a geo position
it's never a list of geo positions
and if you
i don't know what you do with the
restrictions or how you prevent i mean
there is a there is an option for
locator pane
which determines whether you can create
a new locator position or not
right that option is locater auto create
okay well fine so located auto create
can be set to true false whatever
by default but i think this is the
direction we're going anybody object to
this direction
i don't think so okay great sounds like
the right thing
i mean we're not covering what what are
we deciding with the second argument
and we want to download the polygon if
there is a
geo region there and display it on the
map
i see what you're saying okay so the
question is
the default displayed area
encloses the geo region
so we could follow what geographics does
if you write the entity it shows the
area of the entity but if you write
polygon of the entity it starts
showing actually the polygon of the yeah
that sounds right to me
that sounds right that sounds like a
reasonable way to do it because i think
a lot of the time
just say it's going to be somewhere in
illinois i don't need to show the border
of illinois
you know the fact that i could get a
little piece of indiana there
okay if i drop my pin in a piece of
indiana maybe it doesn't work
but i don't think we need to preciously
show where the border is
you see what i'm saying right
okay seems right to me okay let's build
it
um and in terms of the appearance of the
locators
i i think well i don't know whether we
maybe want to make this big or different
color but i don't
i'm not a big i don't think you should
be able to move around
the marker pins i think this is a better
metaphor for what to move around
what do people think i mean
i don't know that i care that much what
the
marker looks like you know but i think
it's very much
going to be a click to place the marker
as opposed to like try to drag it
because um
i mean we can probably make it work with
with dynamic geographics but you know
you know so there's that conflict
between moving the pin and moving the
map yes
well let's try moving the pin initially
although
how does that work on on you know when
you pick
up you know like a pickup location for a
ride share or something on your phone
how do you you know what that's a piece
of ui i remember that
i thought that piece of ui was really
broken yeah they have that issue as well
right i mean i think i mean it's been a
while since i've tried it in like google
maps
but i think you know once you have a pin
it's sort of
there and you have i mean you can't just
pick it up and move it somewhere else
i've seen two different ux
right now long click right hard click
hard press or something right good luck
on discovering that
sorry who was saying they've seen a
couple of ux's
um uh me so um uh one where you
you can drop drag the map and drop a pin
anywhere
and then another where your location is
i'm set in the middle of the map and you
drag the map
all right yes
the dragging the map thing is really
weird
i agree and especially when it's it's on
website it's terrible
because it hijacks scrolling as well
well but on our phone maybe there's a
reason why people have that ux
yeah but usually on the phone like if
you have a map on a website
usually it's bad if you have a map
within google maps that's
all map and doesn't have any website
chrome around it that's
usually decent but whenever i end up on
a website that has a map i want to kill
myself
okay uh
well i think we have to build this and
see what it's like okay because it's
going to be on
a web form but we can have some special
responsive behavior there
yeah i think i think that the the the
web version is already half done
that's why i called this because wp is
ahead on these controllers
great so excellent yeah maybe you want
to review that before we do the
desktop version i don't know well i
think we should get this desktop version
built in the way that you've built it in
the three-liner yeah
basically right and
you know let's get that built let's make
sure it agrees with the web version and
then we're good good to go
here the the only thing is that the the
plus minus
for the zoom is not accessible
oh god oh well then
don't let you drop the freaking pin
there right i mean
i think we can have a have a reserved
way
yeah i think you have to have a reserved
area and where
but but for ux purposes in that reserved
area there has to be a hover effect
and in fact there should be a hover
effect right now when you go over the
plus minus
there was i wonder why yeah but maybe
it's been disabled by the located pane
that's possible okay have a hover effect
have that be reserved area
now wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute i'm totally
confused okay so then
oh what the heck is going on see as soon
as i click to pan it
i'm going to move the locator
okay listen i think the ux should be
this
okay i think the ux should be it comes
up initially with a locator in the
middle
okay you can if you click away from the
locator
you are just on the base map and you're
panning the base map
and um
if you pick up the locator by going to
the locator
it's you know kind of um
switches to that then you pick it up and
you move it somewhere
i think that's the right ux
um
what about double clicking well yes
that's something we get to do on um
uh okay actually a couple of points here
so this is ethan is complaining about
multi-touch and i don't i thought that
was finally coming
does anybody know in the cloud doesn't
the cloud
pinch zoom and so on does now work in
the cloud does it not
on a phone wait uh if you are in a form
anything that works on your browser
works
so i understand that if you're in a
notebook does it work
that i don't know but i think it's it
doesn't concern us here with this
now i understand it's different here but
i'm just looking at that
it's worth raising that question because
i thought that was a solved problem now
but i'm not absolutely certain about
that
i can look on my phone here
um okay anyway is that that
um who's project managing here kevin i
can i can ask
cloud team
boy it's kind of outrageous that my
cloud
this app is is has very old things in it
wow um
okay in any case weird
okay i've got a bunch of universes here
the better to nft them or something
oh okay pinch zoom is the best zoom
anything's saying it doesn't work it
only resizes
the entire graphic
oh as opposed to zooming on a piece of
it okay that's a different discussion
um perhaps that can be in the user
experience user assistance meeting if
nothing else
um okay alcoholic here is saying
drop the map and long press or double
tap
to place a pin
okay so so look the problem is we're
dealing with the phone the touch case
and the okay i don't think we quite have
the right set of people here but but
clearly
okay i think on on in a browser without
touch it seems to me that this thing
about
you know skeuomorphically pick up the
pin and move it somewhere
is a good ux now in that case
if you're going to create a new pin how
do you do that
and for that you might need a pin
spawning point
that is you might need something which
will create a new pin
somewhere if auto locator you know
whatever it is create locator is set to
true
do you see what i'm saying you might
need a a stable for pins
somewhere i'll draw a little fence
around it on everything
quite okay but no but but seriously and
okay look that case is going to be the
minority case
of of whether where you can create new
locators the
the majority case is going to be a
single locator
okay
i mean i do think there may be a case
for example in some of our quizzing
stuff where it says
you know click all countries that were
neutral in world war ii or something
you see what i'm saying you go i thought
you was gonna be a chris
so we were talking about this before but
so there are two options
either you're building something where
you you're using
um geo recognize on the location that
you get out of this
but selecting a geo region is a
different thing
from selecting um just a point
like you you want the you know you want
it to look more like a g-region plot
i guess i agree and that is a different
case
right i mean geoposition setter
could conceivably have some option that
says
don't select points select i mean
maybe that that should be differently
called maybe it should be called
geo region setup or something or geo
region
yeah i think yeah because it probably is
different i mean you might want to
you know like selecting us a whole city
a road
a country a river
yep i i mean it shouldn't be called geo
position if it doesn't return the jew
because it doesn't bind to the
opposition
absolutely well so then it will be geo
region but it isn't a is it a sata
what's the i think so still i mean just
setting an entity instead of
what's the difference between saturn
picker
in in in control naming
what pickers let's see list picker for
example
oh because
i'm not certain because this is
anybody know is is um no i don't know
i mean you're picking you know multiple
things from a finite set
oh i see i see it's not a setter
as in so i mean this would be the geo
region setup would be modeled after geo
region value plot
look i think that's geo-region set up
but then
then what's the default what are you
doing by default
it's like
you know it's hard to have something
which comes up with a thing you know you
know
but that if we look at list picker you
know
it's a two argument thing there's no one
argument form of it
i see so that's what you would have like
you know something
or right geo region picker and then it
has
the dynamic piece is the picked you know
as the pick list
and the the second argument is either
you know it might be something like
counties or something or
county or some such other thing or it
might be a list of entities
exactly that makes sense to me
it's kind of nice so one of them is like
an instantaneous
i mean like if we were doing this for
time for dates
presumably we have a date picker where
you can again select
you want to pick days weeks months
whatever perhaps
whereas something we probably don't have
yeah okay so this is an interesting
analogy we don't have instantaneous time
set up probably we don't have a way of
you're on a timeline
pick an instantaneous time
do you see what i'm saying
[Music]
yes
uh
um so which we don't need in that case
but so in the
in the date case it's more like a date
picker
maybe i don't know date center is
presumably we have the date set of
things anyway this looks right to me geo
position setup
geo region picker um the ux
for geo region picker is just going to
be you click to get that region
you click again and it goes away
um the list picker you can also
press ctrl or shift or alt
to deselect things so it can i was
suggesting
it toggle these selects but maybe that's
wrong
i would toggle deselect well then we
also have
the toddler bar that does what you're
talking about but the picker doesn't do
that
i see well the other problem is for the
picker you've also got the
the dynamic controls like the pan
control
how do you do the pan control if how do
you do a pan control
if clicking adds an item
okay these are ux problems let's let's
look at them separately maybe
maybe somebody could ask noah if he has
an idea for what to do
okay but i think we've got a direction
here for geoposition setter joe regent
picker
makes sense i think so okay
okay so i don't think we need uh lu
carlo
brett for the rest okay okay talk to you
later
thanks bye-bye uh
stephen i forgot to ask you to update
documentation
so these are three minor things
um so then implemented the string
tech drop function i think this had been
requested by user
yes and we i mean the
design of number digit which was called
nth digit last week
has been changed to as we discussed and
then
um interval remember you'll see that the
every time i do a documentation update
and i did one a few hours ago
there's a big pile of stuff that comes
in
yes there's a version approaching
uh
oh we're so happy when the docutools
thing starts looking better
after that revision is done but that's
coming soon
okay string take drop yeah so this was
some pretty
controversial exactly yeah follow intake
drop and string takes trigger drop
that should not indicate 10 plus since
the whole thing is is new
yeah yeah yeah we copied it from tick
drop
or restricted to me okay
and and presumably yeah looks good to me
yeah this is one of these functions that
works well with felpo
sorry fault pair and full part list
right number digits
yes so now it follows the the sign we
discussed
with uh digit corresponding
the digit corresponding to the to two to
the n
and the
real valued number x okay
okay the digit the immediate left the
decimal point
is the zeroth digit yes because the it's
the coefficient of 10 to the
zero right i just wanted to say that so
people wouldn't think it was the first
for some reason yes i understand it
seems to me that
i would say the coefficient of 10 to the
t
doesn't that make sense that's yeah yeah
i mean
depends on whether the readership is all
going to know what coefficient means
some people might
well i guess they will
you don't usually think of coefficients
in a number
well fair enough okay
turns the digit associated with
sure well they fully you know
seems otherwise we're multiplying the
digit multiplying 10 to the n
that'll be fine i mean i i don't know
what people you know i'm sure that in
modern
math elementary math textbooks they have
a whole language about how all this
stuff works and i just don't know what
it is corresponding to
is probably not a term that they use
though
this isn't yet in the prototype build
i don't think it is sorry okay
okay there are some examples
yeah it takes you a moment to realize
why this is for but it's good
that's right perhaps
with a smaller number it will be clearer
yeah
well i don't know i don't think this is
bad
looks good to me okay
what's that third argument of the base
is that a unique thing in that case
what the golden ratio base i think so
yeah i mean as long as it is something
bigger than one oh yeah that's right
okay new operator form for interval
member queue that seems uncontroversial
yep but here they are always the problem
is which one
of the elements of the argument is the
one to be
well what's member queue what is member
queue exactly so we follow member queue
so
okay which has the interval presumably
as its operator form
the interval is the argument no it's
it's the x
no it's the point in
the the point you're checking inclusion
for
i could see arguments for wanting the
interval though
seems better than the mean member queue
okay so the question is
okay in the case of member q what you're
going to want to
i could go either way around right i i
i kind of agree that member queue it's
more natural to have the form
an interval membru it might be more
useful to have the interval just
thinking about
you know inside outside testing and
computational geometry
yes you're not you don't test the same
point against different regions
you test the region against points
exactly typically
how important do we think the
consistency between those two is i'm not
sure it's that important i think it's
more important to have a useful operator
form
i agree with that it's just hard to
remember it is the sort of thing that
probably
requires consulting let's ask around but
i think i
i my initial take would be to have
interval member q
take the interval as the top in its
operator form
what does between this now that i'm
thinking about
well jose the the main change would be
moving an example from properties and
relations to possible issues
okay but the between is doing the thing
that we're now proposing that little
member queue should do
yeah which which is another sign that
we consider this to be more useful yes
fine i think that's what we should do
sauce with
[Music]
uh yes please do switch this interval
number q1
okay okay i think we should probably
wrap up soon but let's just have a quick
look at oh my gosh there's a lot of
these
yeah so this is a new patch and and
they're even more of
of high rank
so what is this rank danny are we
is rank bigger if it's better if it's
bigger or better if it's
no smaller i believe um
i think yeah top rank is one
the most downloaded that's my
understanding
um i would like everybody wants multiple
axes plot yeah
i thought brett was delivering this
um so we just have to ask brett
do you understand i mean that this this
is this we need this
okay face grids behind
that's another good thing
why don't we have this right now from
face grid zero automatic or something
like that
that's another thing we've got to ask
brett
yeah but that's something we should have
map a function of parts of an expression
that match a given pattern
yeah it's a useful thing too
that's basically map act with a
instead of giving its map at cases
it's it's my bad position
it's map f comma expert position expert
comma pattern
no i don't think because i don't think
the levels back
because cases doesn't tell you where to
map it tells you
oh yeah yeah right right right it's it's
it's feeding i'm sure implementationally
it's find the position of that
pattern and then use mapat on that
exactly so i think this is like a map at
position no
no because that's no no no no you you
guys are talking about different things
it shouldn't be called map out position
because although internally it uses
position to find positions and then maps
there
what it is finding is pattern matching
[Music]
yes what i mean is that if we have a
list with two a's
and we say cases is one a do we matter
map at
this is a useful thing right so this is
i mean look at the first example it's
it's
it's doing what map would do except it's
excluding the ones that don't match
pattern
yeah it's like i mean it's like having
this
map if match q whatever
comma pattern f
comma identity
function this is almost replaced isn't
it
but but it does it by by i mean
it's it's doing it in a mapping kind of
way an applying function kind of way
right but it's almost replace pattern
goes to
f of pattern
it is yes
or replace a wall right no because no
it's pattern
it's level it's level spec
well it's an interesting function i i
think i need my
lunch here so i'm i'm rapidly
failing um but let's take a quick look
at some of these others so that one
remains on the docket i'm not quite sure
what to do with it probably needs a
slightly different name
just i just curious what else there is
here
this is green screening function
this is an important area but i don't
know whether this is i don't know how
this relates to what brenton is doing we
should ask brenton how this relates to
that
that's actually why the note says to
brenton for consideration
oh good thank you
you're welcome
all right we're gonna have to do this
another time two regular expression
yeah i mean that's an obviously useful
thing um
probably i mean there's a bunch of
regular expression manipulation
things finite automaton generation etc
all right a lot of good stuff here a lot
of good stuff all right to be continued
another time
um all right
anything else that we absolutely need to
do here
hope okay thanks guys okay see you soon